okay guys okay it's it's your boy
psychobabble with a Donald Trump right
here and we're about to do is crazy
quest that I randomly picked up just
walking around that it said investigate
the Museum of bushcraft and I hear it
too [ __ ] awesome measure them yeah so
look we picked it up so let's do this
I'm traveling forever so I think I just
got here 00 out of here weren't out of
here oh okay private heart who she is
sexy looking at bra um desk this
um Caleb and Anna yes huh flower ok who
the devil's do that is sucked out okay
okay and
listen to the hollow tape mmm ly got the
recorder working so this is sorta detail
you had in mind when you signed up for
the Gunners hauling luggage from
lynnwood for some robot Butler what was
the name of welliton Willingham not now
private where's Connors it's not at his
post oh sorry sir lieutenant study found
some tracks one expects mouth private
Marten tracks what track what the hell
was that oh my color where's the rest of
him oh sure major major one founder oh
[ __ ] okay okay guess it down there's
until this unless you have a good good
gun here my trusty shotgun all right
let's do this boys I stairs changeable
I've got good gut and I got okay Oh what
is it doc no the doctor [ __ ] analyst
Oh God let's go into the base man I like
this I like this
let's blow some [ __ ] out of the water oh
the [ __ ] is that let's just say that
yeah crack all right here's a sweet spot
baybay yeah by right yeah baby
the [ __ ] is up there Oh God God God
goods okay all right
it's just like a deathclaw it sounds a
good day oh yes yes yes yes how God gets
good whoo gold watch the [ __ ] is going
on here oh Jesus whole tables this is
witchcraft
okay so sweet like jump scares some
bugle okay okay wretches what's going on
here better save this ship who knows
what's up there oh oh good you know it's
gonna be a good time oh let's see what
it is knock this [ __ ] off our [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] uh hello good yes Oh should be
burnt at the stake is just getting
[ __ ] up real fast hello sir there's
gonna be a [ __ ] battle you're pretty
soon so let me just check see today's
[ __ ] here yes
it is a death law holy [ __ ] uh I need
something a little stronger than when I
[ __ ] happened 10 a it
ooh that's it like nothing there's that
kid like nothing what dumb [ __ ]
boo boo yah [ __ ] Booya
okay man this dog right let's give him
the fat man because if we don't really
need it right name [ __ ] this [ __ ] is
heavy the high we don't really need
right now and the fat man okay we
[ __ ] save cuz that was a [ __ ]
nightmare night okay right here no woo
some good [ __ ] in here Commonwealth
that's gunner oh it was an egg what the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] I have a a pristine Dethklok okay
um what I got listen to his okay okay I
think it's on masks hips Jeffrey oh you
got oh wait yeah I one rare one be right
there we go oh yes full of dethklok's
what dozen maybe more smash the bits
except this one tell us what was in that
case I'm like no I wouldn't personally
told the gutter bosses and their
glorified liquor cabinet Welling him to
take those diamond city caps and stuff
up I guess we know why then deathclaw
tracked us all away from Linwood's now
huh I stole a damn kids Christ maybe
maybe if we just return the eggs
oh hey mama you're looking for this oh
ok so now we know we got some scrambled
eggs here well we kill them all huh yeah
[ __ ] is this it's in here okay what's my
mission right now data complete delivery
or the egg overturn the egg to its nest
um well we were killed the weather so no
point of returning to the nest turn the
egg to its nest no thank you we're here
that would city yeah okay let's just
which this is complete delivery get that
money baby get that money because I
would love to have a [ __ ] death claw
going nuts and diamonds today would be
interesting a little be me what if I
just ate it
okay okay fast travel in their West
there we go let's do this let's do this
let's do this military style you know
saying you got that depression music
with don't let that [ __ ] get you down by
right here it's sad to dance right bang
[ __ ] oh I gotta choose my weapons up
baby now I got done already where is the
oh yeah baby oh yeah ok ok ok ok boom
shakalaka yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boom
shakalaka yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah touch me where it
they told me not to touch it baby you
know I'm just trying to get by baby I'm
just trying to get by and I went upside
you know what i am saying hmm ok ok ok
yeah we ought to say this [ __ ] ok i got
got got good i was told that be exhale
is it true at a chow but it is a hello
Sam am not there is not [ __ ] here made
Tull's that client time in city security
ok now add again thumb city then
oh it's time once if you like all in
here now I'm going away together that
would set a that a door now
oh here we go hello sir ha ha
the [ __ ] going on over there
is this time at City what do you mean
you can't open the gate stop playing
around Danny I'm standing out in the
open here for crying out loud I got
orders not to let you in miss Piper I'm
sorry just doing my job just doing your
job you her teeth they're [ __ ] up but
I'd say I'm sorry but Mayor McDonough's
really steamed Piper saying that article
you wrote was all lies Oh cities in a
tizzy [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is going on
here Oh
I let them take that out
oh yeah baby oh boomshakalaka I'm a hair
out here talk caller can I put on my dog
my dog Piper who let your back inside I
told Sullivan to keep that gate shut you
devious rabble-rousing slander hey boy
level of Tucson over here in that paper
of yours I'll have that critter scrap
for part a statement mr. McDonough
tyrant mayor shuts down the press why
don't we ask the newcomer you support
the news cuz the mayor's threaten to
throw free speech in the nude yeah I
support news always believed in freedom
of the press Oh didn't mean to bring you
into this argument good sir no no no you
look like diamond city materials oh yeah
let me a dapper a great green jewel of
the Commonwealth safe happy a fine place
to come spend your money settle down
don't let this muckraker here lovin task
a I'm sure your city's a great place
yeah greatest house of cards in the
Commonwealth [ __ ] sexay I've had enough
of this Piper from now on consider you
and that little sister of yours on know
yeah keep talking McDonough that's all
you're good for right hmm a big time in
city welcome from there do you feel
honored yet look I gotta go get settled
in but stop on my office later ooh I
have an idea for an article you be
perfect oh I love erotica okay I get get
get okay anyways I gotta continue this
thing I don't inside
can't wait to release a [ __ ] deadline
huh it looks just like that like bombs
anything oh we're gonna make sure I'm
doing the right one cuz a lot of [ __ ]
going on okay only one thing worth
buying in the dugout in Oh up there okay
I had a [ __ ] do I get up there a real
diamond city boy eats of a noodle see
how the [ __ ] oh this is just like
Megaton
uh hello this is the gentleman's club
you waiting on a delivery yeah yeah what
exactly are you planning to do with the
eggs our plans for the eggs or none of
your guns ok what's your offerings not
enough ok get ya here take it in the
love waits at it guys Wade's at it oh so
close smash the bits on the floor of the
museum of witchcraft you're welcome to
go collect with left I suppose have to
do ya for a less than adequate job but
nonetheless and the special request your
superior made major Jeffries was it I
trust you can get this to its
destination thank you thank you alright
guys it's another successful cause
[ __ ] with yo master of 2006 day
[ __ ] thank you